a lot of the content that I put out guys
it's it's based on studies it's based on
Evo psych it's based on watching human
behavior it's of course based on my
experience in uh you know consumer
content from the manual swamp uh red
pill sort of stuff
um some some a little bit broader and
I've sort of grown and evolved as times
past as I believe one should and update
our belief systems I know that Mackin
has recently read my book
um you had some warm things to say about
it and some not so warm things to say
about it why don't we start with the
book what did you think of the book well
I mean
I think that a lot of your
advice I think that we'd be repeating a
lot of the same things if you know a man
was asking okay what can I do to succeed
better on the mating Market a lot of
just the raw advice we'd say a bunch of
the same things it's like yes focus on
yourself right so it's it's not a
chasing game it's a building game uh
it's about the traits that you bring to
the table more so than
you know just pursuing and pursuing and
pursuing so the idea of like yes women
care about looks so you should try to be
good looking and hit the gym and get
your fashion in order yes women care
about money so yeah you should be trying
to make money if you're ambitious
romantically uh yes women care about
status I mean I would add some things
that you that you probably that you may
or may not agree with
um but that would be a list that we
would have in common
to be honest though mate the overall
attitude towards women in the book and
in your other work it's just something
that I don't relate to at all I like I
just
I mean like even scrolling through your
Twitter like saying things like 90 of
women have nothing to offer in
relationships like I was just I was just
reading it before I go on like 90 of
women have nothing to offer in
relationships but sex
um women are sex objects right uh making
fun of Taylor Swift's body like this is
stuff that like
I just don't relate to it at all it
strikes me as very harmful and it's you
know I mean to be to be 100 Frank it
grosses me out like it's just like I I
I can barely read it but then on the
other end it's like I I do think there's
a baby in the bath water
um we do we do have a lot of
commonalities in the sense that
we wouldn't just tell someone oh just be
yourself
um and we also wouldn't
we wouldn't be a fan of people whining
about the mating market and saying oh
it's unfair that women want these things
or oh it's unfair that guys want these
things and then just hoping that someone
will come along and scoop them up that's
uh anyway I I'm sure that I'm getting
tons of comments from your audience I'm
coming on your platformer here so I'm
sure that I'm getting tons of simp and
white knight and that kind of thing and
uh I'm totally comfortable with that I I
don't need to be liked no it's that's uh
look man I mean you know the internet is
what the internet is and it and it says
and does things that it does and uh you
know you have to learn how to leverage
it too that's that's
um that's one of the skills that I sort
of picked up a few years ago from Ryan
from Ryan holiday he was the author of
uh you know quite a few books and he got
started when he was working for a
clothing company I think it was American
Apparel or Abercrombie and finch or
something just talking about like look
you know if you're going to use social
media if you want to get reached you
have to talk about things in in such a
way that it gets people's attention so
that they want to talk about it or
engage in it and it's a fine line with
social media today because if you go too
far then you can get banned or do
Platform and you're not salacious enough
then you don't get any attention at the
same time so you and I operate in
different Realms you operate in the
scientific realm and I try to get
people's attention on conversation
pieces that I have uh so sometimes I
guess flicking boogers at certain people
is necessary to uh create a little bit
of outrage and attention on it so that's
what I do it and that's how I do that
stuff was that stuff especially like
Twitter
um so you've outraged me a few times so
it's excellent excellent well it was
enough that as soon as I followed you
like literally within about uh 10 to 15
minutes I got a DM from you asking for
eight yeah
well here's the thing is that I mean if
you go on my Tick Tock right every time
I go viral I get tons of comments just
saying oh you're scared to talk to
someone from the red pill you know like
you won't you and it's like I'm not
scared to have a conversation mate like
it's totally fine but every everyone I
reach out to it's like I I respect you
for being the first person uh willing to
willing to touch me with a 10-foot pole
because you know Rolo tomasi has been uh
been ignoring me even though he you know
replies to my other stuff he uh you know
he he's a bit of an alpha male there and
uh a bit too Alpha for a conversation I
suppose what's the um what's the gripe
what's the um issue that
um people seem to have with you on Tick
Tock and you know like the red pill or
like the narratives that are that are
discussed in that space
well it's kind of weird because I get
hate from both sides right I mean I I
the red pill blue pill black I mean it
it just sounds like people talking about
their favorite color Power Ranger to me
yeah let's talk about pills per minute
like what do you think about all these
colored pills that are all labeled now I
think it's I think it's weird to
approach life trying to expect that you
can sort it into ideologies and in this
like neat way
um it's not how I operate I I mean I I
know that a lot of people are just not
going to believe that this is true but
people in my personal life will tell you
that it is it's I believe whatever the
mainstream science and and in some Niche
cases where I think the mainstream
science is wrong it's because I think
there are specific studies that are very
very compelling and and that leads me to
disagree with a lot of mainstream red
pill points it leads me to have kind of
a nuanced take on certain ones it leads
me to outright agree with some right
like if we were talking like if I was
talking to someone who's you know
thoroughly blue pilled if that's even a
thing
um they would tell me oh you know just
again what we're talking about like oh
just be yourself right or oh looks don't
matter right or oh it's just it's just a
stereotype that money is attractive
right like this is just nonsense there's
there's Decades of research showing that
that's not true
and then you know there there's some
people most of my comments are people
misinterpreting me as someone who's just
I mean it depends on what I'm going
viral for I mean sometimes people are
you know calling me an incel and saying
that I'm black pilled and it's like all
right I'm not an in cell and I'm I'm a
hardly black build I just think that the
data is in and looks matter right and
and sometimes it's people saying that
I'm that I'm a you know a simp and a
[__] um because I don't believe that I
don't know
that what would be a good example of
like a non-red pill belief I have that
that I believe that body count matters
for men as much as women or that I
believe that
in terms of dating prospects it's
actually quite uncommon for a woman to
mess up her dating life by having too
much uh you know sexual encounters in
practice it's like that doesn't seem to
be that much of a hurdle or I wouldn't
believe that say I I wouldn't believe in
something like the wall like this idea
that like this like overnight I mean we
can get into all the the detailed things
I think uh yeah I saw that you you sort
of defined the wall as more of a slope
than a definite smash it to a hard
object that stops their prospects yeah I
mean it would be weird if it wasn't I
mean it's like that's not that's not how
aging works it's like yes over time
romantic prospects in terms of your mate
value over time that declines in men it
starts to decline at a significantly
later Point than it does in women but it
declines in both cases right um like
Rich I'm sure you know that you probably
had more options when you were 40 than
you do now right
um like I I don't think that's something
you disagree with you're actually one of
the more frankly I mean I I don't want
to just argue with you or or discuss
things with you as if you're just a
representative for the entire red pill
right uh we talked about this in DM so
we can clarify so yeah you're asking
about that and you know I am what I
would consider red pilled but I am not
identifying with any pill in particular
I have become frustrated and exhausted
with the notion of of pills because
people invent new pills to uh label
whatever belief they want to broadcast
or sell to especially on you know social
media and YouTube so so if the red pill
is in your thing then you conjure up a
white pill or a purple one or an orange
one or you know something like this to
brand and Market whatever it is that
you're selling to me it's it's simply
you know what is truth and what is lies
right and interpretation of Truth
for me because I'm a little bit older
and have some more experience I you know
I look at human behavior I look at what
I've read in Evo psych and I've probably
read close to as much as you have
um not to the same degree I haven't
studied having research I haven't put
out papers like you have obviously and
I've I've summarized a lot of my
thoughts in a a book
um and in content that I put out but I
don't really like the whole you know
let's be red pilled or your blue pill or
if they disagree like I've seen people
in the mantle swamp call guys like David
Buss uh blue pill and I don't think he's
blue pill I think he's a scientist
that's researched some uh great you know
put some good work together and put out
some very informative and useful books
and
um you know call somebody that's that's
put out useful information blue pill
almost seems like it's disparaging at
this point
um so I don't like the whole pill label
labeling stuff I think it's you know
what is actually working and what's
useful that you can apply to your life
and what is just you know comforting
lies to sort of satiate you to happy
wife happy life you know your way
through a marriage you know sort of
thing would be a very simple example to
sort of put out there I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out